when you were talking about you told me
you were quitting I go he isn't quitting
I mean if he walks away from this
nothing's going to be as satisfying and
he's still a young man this is what I
said to Beth he'll he'll continue and uh
you did you signed up for another three
years yeah and also like being
um wanted is important too you know ABC
wanting me to stay which I I didn't know
I was like oh maybe they want to you
know maybe they want to start over maybe
the people running the network now want
to
find a person of their own and put their
imprint and have somebody for the next
20 years or who knows but um yeah
ultimately it was just like I think I I
I was having a hard time
um with the leaving part of it I don't
mean just like leaving I mean just what
you need to go through the emotional
uh toll that that takes of like okay you
got six months now you got to wrap it up
and uh it was easier for me to go I you
know what I'll worry about that in three
years you know what for me it is it's
like when you have something successful
going on where you're wanted and all of
that how do you walk away from that you
know I don't understand it it's
especially when you're from Radio like
we are and you get fired and you're
barely scratching it together and just
trying to make something happen and you
know I was fired from most of my radio
jobs and most of them didn't last a year
and each time I went into it with High
Hopes I'd move across the country I had
two little kids I'd go from you know
Seattle to Phoenix to Tampa to Palm
Springs to Tucson to La you know I had
all these different jobs and I finally
got a job where they liked me in La at
K-Rock and I you know I I was really
like reluctant to leave even when the
man show became pop popular I just it
was just a matter there weren't enough
hours in the day for me to stay and I
think back to that and I think back you
know and I mean I never made more than
sixty thousand dollars a year uh in you
know until like I was three years into
K-Rock you know and most of those jobs I
made much less than that so the idea of
quitting a job is uh I don't know it's
like like I I can't imagine explaining
that to my 25 year old self right yeah
that's how I feel too so you know good
I'm listening I'm glad you're staying on
I feel good about it it actually gives
me Comfort
foreign